question la parole est à connaître mélo
pour le mouvement
UMP
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
portera sur les conditions de vie
étudiante et notamment sur l'accès des
étudiants un logement selon deux
enquêtes récentes et distinctes de
l'UNEF et de la phase le coût de la
rentrée étudiante a augmenté de 1,6% par
rapport à l'année dernière le logement
représente le principal poste de
dépenses en moyenne 500 euros par mois
en région et 700 euros à l'Île-de-France
soit 55% du budget total des étudiants
les étudiants sont donc de plus en plus
nombreux à devoir travailler pour
financer leurs études et cela au
détriment de leur parcours universitaire
face à l'absence de revalorisation des
aides au logement l'accès à un logement
privé devient de plus en plus difficile
pour la majorité des étudiants du fait
des loyers élevés auxquels il convient
de rajouter des charges locatives et
prendre en compte les augmentations
d'électricité ou du gaz
d'autre part les logements sociaux
destinés aux étudiants sont en nombre
insuffisants je souhaiterais donc
connaître les mesures que vous comptez
prendre concernant les logements sociaux
le président de la République s'était
engagé sur un objectif précis de
construction de 40 000 logements d'ici
2017 comment s'est engagement se
traduira-t-il précisément dans la loi de
finances 2014 je tiens à préciser que
sur ce sujet les associations étudiantes
ont rappelé que les 20 millions d'euros
accordés au cnus pour ces projets de
logement ne suffiront pas à dynamiser la
construction de logements sociaux
concernant le parc privé certaines
agences immobilières requiert un nombre
très important de pièces à fournir tant
par l'étudiant lui-même que par les
garants qui se voient réclamer des avis
d'imposition des bulletins de salaire et
autres justificatifs vous venez de
mettre en place pour la rentrée 2013 un
dispositif national de cautionnement
solidaire son annonce yant était tardive
et le public visé ant particulièrement
restreint étudiant issus d'une famille
homonoparentale étudiant isolée
étrangers pourriez-vous nous dire Madame
la Ministre combien de personnes seront
finalement concernés comptez-vous par la
suite élargir ce dispositif à l'ensemble
des étudiants puisqu'ils sont finalement
tous concernés par les difficultés
d'accès au logement merci merci chers
collègues madame la ministre
ce président merci madame la sénatrice
de cette question puisque vous savez que
la réussite étudiante est au cœur des
priorités de ce gouvernement et de la
loi sur l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche qui était votée en juillet
dernier et nous savons bien les
conditions de vie en particulier les
conditions de logement comptent pour
beaucoup dans la réussite des étudiants
alors vous l'avez dit il représente le
coût des loyers représente 55% du budget
des étudiants en région à Paris il peut
atteindre jusqu'à 70% autrement dit un
étudiant n'a plus que peu d'argent pour
se nourrir avoir accès à la culture
avoir accès à la santé faire du sport
bref faites faire tout ce qui contribue
à faire réussir les études alors dans
les 10 dernières années le plan Anciaux
avait prévu 70 000 habitations et 50000
constructions ce qui a été réalisé entre
2007 et 2012 par rapport à ce plan c'est
à peu près la moitié 36 000
réhabilitations mais beaucoup moins pour
les constructions il y en a eu que 19000
le président de la République m'a fixé
une feuille de route effectivement
ambitieuse de 40 000 logements sur quand
nous en avons déjà identifié à la suite
d'une mission confiée à un préfet
Prévost nous en avons identifié 30 000
dans le cadre des plans campus que nous
avons débloqué en fluidifiant et en
diversifiant les procédures en sortant
du tout PPP des contrats de projets de
ta région que nous relançons et enfin du
levier supplémentaire que nous avons
donné aux ce n'est pas seulement 20
millions d'euros c'est 20 millions
d'euros de plus par rapport aux 70
millions d'euros précédents que le cnus
a obtenu par notre augmentation du
budget nous avons augmenté de 7% la vie
étudiante nous avons également dégagé
400 millions d'euros nouveaux pour les
bourses sur trois ans c'est un effort
historique c'est ce qu'on dit les
présidents des organisations d'étudiants
et vous savez qu'ils ne sont souvent pas
tendres et qu'ils sont à juste titre
assez exigeants donc 400 millions
d'euros de plus sur trois ans c'est un
premier pas vers la location d'études
que nous nous sommes engagés à mettre en
place sur les 50 donc des efforts sur le
logement des efforts sur les revenus des
étudiants pour leur permettre notamment
de travailler moins parce qu'on sait que
15 heures par semaine ils mettent en
danger leurs études et tout cela devrait
contribuer fortement à la réussite des
étudiants nous avons livré dès cette
rentrée de septembre
8500 logements la moitié en
réhabilitation la moitié en construction
merci Madame la Ministre madame Melo
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour les précisions que vous
devez que vous venez de me donner nous
ne manquerons pas à l'avenir de faire de
faire un nouveau bilan mais concernant
le cautionnement solidaire une priorité
est fixée pour les personnes ayant des
difficultés à trouver un cautionnement
mais le problème des étudiants vient
également du manque de confiance des
propriétaires dans la caution proposée
par les étudiants d'où la nécessité
d'élargir le dispositif pour que l'État
soit garant pour tous sinon une
inégalité sera créée pour les étudiants
ayant une caution ordinaire et pas une
caution d'État je vous remercie de le
prendre en compte merci chers collègues
la parole